One of the great things about the liver
is that it regenerates,
so if you cut out somebody half of
someone's liver,
it grows back.
That's why we can now not only use
cadaver livers,
but we can use,
we can use portions of living donors.
Um,
it's entirely possible that,
that,
um,
and there's work being done in this area
that in the future,
a liver transplant will be no more than
an injection of a number of cells that
will implant somewhere in the body and
will grow and form an entire new liver.
So this is the whole area of stem cell
transplantation.
Um,
and then I think the last area,
um,
and this is a fairly controversial area,
but I think has great potential,
um,
and,
and the background here is that as you
may be aware,
there are many people,
particularly with liver disease,
many more people that need livers than
we currently have livers for.
Um,
there's a whole area called
xenotransplantation in which the idea is
that we would take animals,
pigs big,
currently the preferred animal and be
able to modify them genetically in such
a way that a human would not only not
reject a pig liver,
but that any potential diseases that
would be unique to a animals would not
be able to be contracted by a human.
This is a big,
a big concern right now that,
that you could envision 20 years from
now,
everyone who needs a liver having access
to one because you would walk into,
um,
and I'm just as,
I'm just imagine you walk into a
facility,
you take out a pig and you'll use the
pig liver for the,
for the patient or the pig pen.
So I think,
I think,
um,
I think technical advances in the,
in the,
uh,
leading to minimally increasingly
minimally invasive surgery,
um,
a new drugs and ultimately a sufficient
understanding of the immune system that
no drugs would be necessary.
Um,
um,
the use of cells rather than whole
organs.
And potentially the use of animal organs
are probably the four areas of the
future with when it comes to to solid
organ trail.